when we change our relationship with
uncomfortable feelings whether that's
stress anxiety whatever those sort of
uncomfortable feelings are if we're
willing to have them and use them to our
advantage and take them with us then
they don't hold us back
his most recent study about the the
active ssris and the serotonogic system
and how it's related to depression
uh I think that there's been lots of
sort of news headlines going on but I
think it's not unusual for there to be
headlines about things like medication
so to be fair it's not something I've
hugely engaged with because I'd sort of
rather go to the source of which I
haven't been to yet so
um yeah I try in general I try to sort
of steer clear of
um some of the headlines partly because
they can get it really really wrong
um but I assume there's a brand new
study it looks like it yes so this is
from the conversation.com depression is
probably not caused by a chemical
imbalance in the brain this is the
people that have done the study uh the
serotonin theory of depression has been
one of the most influential and
extensively researched biological
theories of the origins of depression
our study shows that this view is not
supported by scientific evidence it also
calls into question the basis for the
use of antidepressants most
antidepressants now in use are presumed
to act on their effect via serotonin
some also affect the brain via
noradrenaline but experts agree that the
evidence for the involvement
noradrenaline and depression is weaker
than that for serotonin there's a bunch
of mechanisms basically things are now
up in the air and chemical imbalance is
something which appears to be being
criticized and looked at with a lot more
cynicism
yeah and I think it's not the first
study to
um sort of indicate that and there's
been you know there are sort of you know
books written on it and and things over
the years but I mean from someone who's
who's not a medic so I'm a psychologist
so we focus on sort of psychological
formulation and looking at how people
can manage their mental health through
skills work and and therapy actually you
know I it does sort of ring true that
you know there are some people that
might come along with the idea that
um it's something that is wrong with
them and you know there's something in
my brain that's not right and I need
fixing and and there's other other
people that don't necessarily come along
with that
um conceptual idea of of things that are
happening to them
um and often will work you know whatever
idea somebody has about the origins of
their distress
uh we tend to I tend to work from
an individual basis so whether there is
or they're not there isn't
um uh you know an exact sort of
biological cause actually I've never
come across anybody
um once you hear somebody's story
um and and everything that they've been
through from from the word go
I I've never been through that whole
process of hearing somebody's story
without then
thinking of course of course you feel
this way look at everything you've been
through why wouldn't you it'll be
strange if you weren't suffering the
effects of that trauma or you know this
relationship or whatever that person has
been through so I've always been able to
you know from the psychological
perspective
I've always been able to make sense of
people's distress through their life
story and what's happened to them and
the way that they are
um sort of choosing to cope with it and
their different sort of coping
mechanisms and and by adjusting some of
those we can have you know massive
Transformations and how people function
well let's say for a second at the
serotonin theory was correct and that is
what happens I'll be very very surprised
if the person with even the worst
serotonin in the world but was getting
up on time and had great relationships
and was eating and drinking right and
trained and got sufficient sunlight and
that that person is going to be
unbelievably resilient and the same for
the person that has the perfect
serotonin balance in the brain if you
kill their sleep for two weeks make them
eat terrible food keep them in a dark
space and give them no friends to be
around or work that's meaningful to them
I challenge the happiest person on the
planet to not feel depressed after that
exactly and and it's sort of strange
this idea that
um you know you the chemical balance in
your brain is is the start of everything
actually it's also a reflection of
what's happening around you and in your
life so yeah if you if you change your
behavior you can change your brain
chemistry we you know um while our
medication can be really effective at
doing that there are also lots of other
things that we can do that we can take
control of that impact our brain
chemistry as well Andrew heedman came on
the show a couple of weeks ago and he's
got this quote where he says you cannot
control the mind with the mind and he's
just talking about the fact that our
brain states are intrinsically linked to
the actions that we take to the way that
we do things on a daily basis and then
actually getting out of the mind and
into the body is something that's maybe
quicker than and they're not trying to
think our way out of whatever problem it
is that we're facing
uh yeah certainly the sort of the
skills that tap into
um the physical Sensations are often the
first that we would teach in therapy
partly because they are quick acting
they are really easy skills to learn and
ones that you can then use whenever you
need to uh like the sort of different
breathing techniques and you know Andrew
human talks um really well about this
sort of the different ways you can use
breathing to kind of calm anxiety and
stress and those kind of things which is
really really helpful so they're often
the first things that would be taught to
somebody
who came to therapy for example I think
while you can you can influence the Mind
through the mind it's a a more long-term
strategy so it's stuff that takes more
practice you know you can learn a
breathing technique in in 10 minutes and
then use that forever
um but also you can learn how to change
your relationship with your thought
patterns or your past and that's the
stuff that takes longer
um but also has an incredible long-term
effect what do you think most people get
wrong when trying to understand anxiety
uh what do they get wrong
um possibly the idea that
they can influence it that it's a
feeling like any other and
um that when you have that feeling you
don't have to be at the mercy of it
there are lots of things you can do to
influence the intensity of it and bring
the intensity of that down so that you
can function at your back you know we
can use that threat response that stress
response to our advantage and and it
helps us to stay alert to perform to do
what we need to do to survive all of
those things
but we have to sort of understand the
system and work with the system rather
than against it so if we try like any
other feeling if we're trying not to
have it and we're trying to squash it or
numb it out then that's going to cause
more problems than if we allow it to be
there and use it Frontage what about the
opposite let's say that somebody was
feeling anxious and you wanted to
prescribe them away to make that feeling
be as intense as possible to last for as
long as possible what what would you get
somebody to do that was feeling anxious
that could make it worse
well that's interesting because there
are lots of things that we do that we
think make anxiety better but actually
making it worse and the number one thing
I would say there is avoidance so when
we feel anxious our body is telling us
to escape and then avoid that thing
right because that's how our friends are
set up to to help us survive and and
that works right if
um if you're in a situation where there
is a threat to your survival it makes
sense that you get out of there get safe
and then don't go back but in today's
society and where there are lots of
psychological threats your brain works
the same so if there's a threat to
um maybe uh sort of Abandonment or
rejection or
um if you feel that you're going to be
humiliated in a situation
um you have that same response your
brain says this is not safe you get out
of here and you don't go back but if you
do that with your workplace or social
situations then you don't end up
building your confidence in the work
situation you if you avoid it uh it gets
harder to go back right it gets it
builds up that anxiety even more so when
we avoid the thing that we fear the
anxiety gets worse over time and and
often that's why you know in treatments
exposure graded exposure is part of
um overcoming all sorts of anxiety
disorders I think people presume that
exposure therapy is for
a fear of snakes or some phobias you
know like real in your face stuff but
the fact that it exists for emotions as
well for situations that
presentation you've got to give in front
of the group that boss that you hate
having a conversation around and I guess
you know to a more intense period even
just going out of the house going to
shops stuff like that I think
a lot of the people that listen to this
podcast will be high functioning
individuals there'll be people that are
doing really well but if they look back
to whatever five or ten years ago and
they didn't have the tools that they
have and they realized just how fragile
they were at that point you go well hang
on a second yeah this is there are
complete gradients to this and everybody
is always playing at the level that
they're at now
yeah and and that's where we can really
learn from all of these incredible tools
that are taught in therapy they're also
helpful for everybody else and who may
not be in therapy or may not even feel
that they need therapy actually if if
there's something you want to master and
it makes you nervous do it as much as
you possibly can at the only way to
build your confidence in something or to
reduce your anxiety about something is
to do it more and more and more and you
know the things that we do every day
become our comfort zone so if you're
going to
um you know if if speaking in public is
going to get any easier for you the only
way to do that is do that more often but
we do it in a graded way so don't expect
yourself to go and speak in front of 10
000 people and be okay with that you
build up to it so you take
um you know that first sort of layer
outside of your comfort zone that feels
difficult feels like a challenge but is
manageable you do that and you repeat it
again and again and again until that
feels like nothing really it's just easy
and then you know then your comfort zone
expands and there's another thing that
feels more of a challenge so you do that
so you work up and up and up and and you
sort of get closer towards those things
initially you feel like a worst case
scenario but when you get closer to it
doesn't feel so extreme one of the nice
things about making progress I think is
that you can look back at the things
that used to be a challenge to you and
barely even remember that they were
something that was difficult you know
you look at them now and it's just it's
absolutely nothing and yeah I suppose
that that exponential growth that you're
talking about is precisely because of
that that it starts off with something
small and then you gradually take bigger
steps and then after five or ten years
of doing personal development you look
back and you go I can't even believe
that I I don't even think about that
thing anymore
given the fact that thoughts a lot of
the time especially anxious thoughts
cause us to obsess and mentally do
thought loops around them what's the
solution to break the cycle of anxious
thoughts
well I guess first of all the don't do
is don't try not to have them you know
if which if you're trying not think
about something you're already thinking
about it and so uh if we you know
thoughts arrive in your mind because
your brain is constantly taking in
information from your outside world and
then offering up to you ideas of how to
interpret that and and they are ideas
they're theories their Concepts their
stories maybe their influenced by memory
as well a lot of the time and so that's
where they are one possible perspective
and so the way that we kind of then
shift our relationship with those
thoughts is to understand that and
acknowledge that even as thoughts arrive
so you know one big sort of sort of
biased thought pattern you would have
when you're anxious is catastrophizing
so your mind goes to the worst possible
case scenario and it plays out for you
in your mind like a horror movie on
repeat and and it that becomes the idea
that this is going to happen because
I've thought it now and we kind of take
on that thought as if it's absolute
truth and we run it over and over again
and then our anxiety gets worse and
worse and worse but if we acknowledge
that thought as a catastrophizing
thought which is a bias right it's it's
your your brain offering up the worst
case scenario because you're already
feeling anxious
then we take some of the power out of it
by acknowledging that it's not a given
fact it's not the one true reflection of
reality it's one possible way of looking
at this and there are others so by doing
that you're just stepping back from it
and you're allowing yourself the
possibility of seeing things from
another perspective but without that
it's you know if we just accept every
thought that arrives as fact and a true
reflection of reality then it has much
more power over how we feel than what we
do and how we behave and all of those
sorts of things so
um I think it's about shifting your
relationship with thoughts not trying to
stop them from arriving but allowing
them to arrive and then seeing them for
what they are which is one story
why do you think catastrophizing would
be adaptive
because if you're in a a dangerous
situation you know if we kind of you
know go back a thousand years and and
you're in a dangerous situation then if
you cannot predict what might happen in
this situation then you might miss
something and you're out of there you
know you're gone so actually it is your
brain working at its best to keep you
you know your brain's sort of main
function is not to keep you happy and
calm is to keep you alive so it's there
to tell you I know what you know the
worst possible thing that could happen
in this situation I'm going to present
it to you and then our job is to work
out is that likely are there other
perspectives here and and then what am I
going to do about it so it's kind of
like the the negativity bias but
projected forwards onto events that
haven't occurred yet in an attempt to
mean make sure that we are regularly not
going to push ourselves towards
something that may end up killing us
yeah so I you know if I go up uh onto
The Cliffs by the coast and I'm walking
with my children and my child I'm
already aware by the time we step out
the car and the Cliff's still 50 yards
away but I'm already thinking someone
could fall over the edge and and that is
the way I keep my children safe right
you you go to the worst case scenario
and and that enables you to act in a way
that prevents that bad thing from
happening whereas if you never had the
thought in the first place you might not
put the safety
um behaviors in place but I guess the
the trick there then becomes to to work
out which of those sort of thoughts are
warranted as a as a you know something
that may happen and is likely to happen
or some small child's near Cliff
probably worthwhile thinking about
exactly right and um but if it's a if
it's a different situation
um if it's a you know I don't know
um or I've got a pain in my leg maybe
there's cancer there you know you kind
of jump to that worst case scenario
whereas the possibility of that is less
likely and and so we can never have so
certainty right it's always ideas that
our brain is offering up to us and and
we have to be able to tolerate that
uncertainty of not really knowing
exactly what's going to happen
um but balancing our our choice of
behavior and safety Behavior with how we
want to live our lives so if I feel
anxious about going to the supermarket
and the worst case scenario is you know
I'm going to have a panic attack in
there and feel humiliated and from that
I then make the life choice never to
return to a supermarket
um that's probably going to
significantly impact the quality of my
life if I'm not able to get food when I
need to and those sorts of things so
um it's yeah it's always making those
sort of judgment calls around when am I
going to respond to that feeling and
when am I going to
um to you know make choices based on my
values have you looked at the behavioral
genetics stuff around depression and its
heritability
how do you mean so the it seems like the
heritability of depression from parent
to child is a lot higher than I would
have thought not higher than behavioral
geneticist sort of thought because they
always knew that it was everything's
highly heritable
um but I just think about you know when
it's the person that's terrified of
going to the shops that seems like such
an extreme response and it seems like
the sort of thing that would almost be
difficult to learn without being primed
prior to that without having a
predisposition toward that and it's just
one of the things since learning about
behavioral genetics with Robert blowman
who was the kind of the granddaddy of it
a couple of years ago it really has
given me a lot more
sympathy I think for people that have
differing mental States and that
includes people that are unbelievably
extroverted or confident or whatever
because a lot of the things that we have
have just been imbued to us through our
genes but that it doesn't really matter
whether you do or don't have it that's
the game that you're playing those are
the rules and the physics of the system
that you're working within you don't get
to change that from the moment that
you're born you don't get to change that
what you do get to change is the top
level stuff in terms of the inputs in
terms of the environment in terms of
blah blah blah
um but yeah it just
the range of ways that humans can
mentally show up
doesn't surprise me given the fact that
we're so varied when it comes to our
genes our exposures our environments and
all of that
yeah and and you know I as a
psychologist we always see you know
those sort of genetic vulnerabilities as
rather than fate potentials and and so
um you know you could come into the room
and no one has any idea whether you've
got a genetic vulnerability to your
situation or not
so we work the same with everybody so
it's you know yes
if you have a genetic vulnerability or
you don't
we can still impact on the expression of
those genes through everything you do
and everything you put into your life
and everything you take out of it and so
um I think sometimes the danger of
um
sort of making that the dominant part of
a conversation mental health is that
people can feel hopeless about it you
know that I've experienced you know
bouts of depression throughout my life
therefore
it must be inherited and therefore I'm
doomed to have it for the rest of my
life and actually if that person was to
go to a therapy and learn some of the
Arsenal of tools that are available to
to prevent relapse for depression and to
manage mood and and you know those
things can be transformative and I've
seen that I've seen people sort of pull
them back from situations that you would
never believe people could pull
themselves back from and we have no idea
whether they had the genetics for that
or not we just did the work and and made
the change and so I I think I have to in
my practice believe that that is
possible for everybody I think it's the
same as the broken brain serotonin
system that it's incredibly
disempowering that was why I love
um Johann hari's lost connections it was
the first book I know that there's
criticisms of that book and some of the
research and stuff but it was the first
book that I'd read that put the Lions
share of your mood in your hands and I
just found that to be as somebody that
was suffering with depression throughout
his 20s I thought it was so great to
hear that because it made me think okay
like I've got control over this and yeah
the same when people walk through the
doors of your practice you know they
need to they need to believe that they
can walk out if they're making changes
and they can I mean you know I've had
some friends that have been in some
pretty dark places and then they've put
the work in and they come out the other
side and they're unrecognizable you go
if that guy can do it if he can turn it
around then I'm pretty sure anybody can
yeah and I think in some ways that's
been the bulk of my work clinically has
been
um seeing that transformation in people
where they arrive in the therapy room
believing that
um they're getting something wrong about
life and that they're not
um they're not doing things in the way
that everybody else seems to be because
they feel terrible and feeling that they
have no real control over that and and
once they learn that there are things
that can really really help
um and you know some of it's more
difficult than others but actually there
are some sort of pretty simple things
you can put into your life and make sure
you prioritize that can make a huge
difference and and once people you know
realize that potential to have some more
of the sort of locus of control within
themselves and their own choices
um it's just transformative for for so
many people and and that's really why I
started sort of sharing videos and
writing the book and that kind of thing
was to just make some of that
um education available to people how is
stress different from anxiety
so um when when we come to sort of
Stress and Anxiety it's really about how
we conceptualize those experiences so we
have that that one threat system that we
you know everyone talks about the fight
or flight and and we talk about that
when we we are often discussing kind of
anxiety
uh but I I sort of I love the
the sort of concept of uh let's say
let's say you got a meeting at work and
you've got an hour before then you
really need to go to the post office so
you dash down there you you get there
and you know you've got just enough time
to to post that thing and then get get
back to your meeting
but you arrive and there's a huge line
there's a huge queue that you've got to
get into in order to
um you know post your parcel and you
immediately feel this Rush of uh you
know your heart's pounding the sweaty
palms and you're suddenly hyper alert am
I going to get back in time for my
meeting and what you're what's happening
there is your brain is increasing your
level of alertness it's It's using that
stress response to enable you to
re-prioritize if you need to and think
about do I need to be here or do I need
to go back and make sure I get to that
meeting in time
so it's really um you know we would
conceptualize that sort of situation as
stress I would say when we talk about it
and use the word anxiety it might be
similar physical Sensations you know the
sweaty palms and the heart pounding but
it's generally going to be more
associated with a threat so you know
maybe you were due to speak at that you
know work meeting in front of a hundred
people and you would be absolutely
humiliated if you were going to be late
and so you know the idea of public
humiliation would fill you with what you
would probably call anxiety you know
that it just feels sort of more
threatened threat based
um
and so you know I think there's there's
still a lot of sort of work going on
about understanding whether those two
responses are very different
biologically and whether we can find
those markers but I think really it's
how we conceptualize it and often when
we talk about
um stress or anxiety or any other
feelings
a lot of people ask me how do I know if
I'm feeling this or how do I know if I'm
feeling that and often the answer is it
really doesn't matter if you're feeling
something and you give it a word you
give it a label that's already helping
you to cope with it whether that label
matches other people's label for their
feelings or not is not so important if
you're able to give words to how you
feel and label those things
um then you're already helping your
brain to sort of process it and
understand it and predict
um what that means for you in the future
I heard about young kids in Primary
School
being taught mindfulness practices and I
think that they were naming them as kind
of different characters
Mr Blue or Mr Green or the the nasty
pirate or something like this and you're
right it kind of shows oh how stupid the
kids are naming their emotions colors or
about Pirates but there's nothing that's
inherently any more virtuous about that
word than calling it stress or anxiety
that the the choice of letters that
represent the emotion is totally
arbitrary and the distancing that you
get this is the beautiful thing of
noting when it comes to meditation you
notice a sensation arise in
Consciousness you note the fact that it
is Arisen and then it falls away it's
the noting fact that actually matters
it's not the words that you give it yeah
it's just like the sort of thought bias
labeling by just giving it a label what
you do is you step back from it you get
a bit of a kind of bird's eye view which
enables you to see it for what it is
which is not who you are it's a
sensation it's an experience that's sort
of washing over you if you like and and
by doing that we I mean
um in the book I talk about
um the the it feels like such an old
movie now but I remember the Jim Carrey
movie The Mask and and he kind of it
looked the mask looks like nothing it's
just this kind of old wooden mask but
when he holds it close to his face it
kind of grips around the back of the
head and then it impacts on everything
he does everything he says everything he
feels and and it's a bit like that with
with thoughts and emotions
when when they're sort of here and we
can't see anything else and we just
absorb that as that you know that is
fact this is all I'm willing to see and
feel then it impacts on everything
and the idea of kind of giving something
a label or stepping back from it and
observing it so observing that it's an
experience that's washing past us it's
like you know when Jim Carrey kind of
takes the mask off and he just holds it
at arm's length it's just a mask then
it's it's no longer got the same power
it's still in his hand it's not far away
from his face but it's just enough
distance to give him that perspective to
see the thing for what it is
foreign I think one of the most
important things I've learned about
reframing stress uh and I guess you
could call it anxiety as well is how
much of an effective performance
enhancer it is as soon as you stop
judging yourself or fearing it it's some
of the best performances that I've had
whether it be on the podcast whether it
be at work in my previous job has been
geared by the fact that I'm stressed by
it like unbelievably stressed but
a lot of it if you can learn to be
excited by and I actually have now I've
got a couple of big things coming up
over the next couple of weeks that I'm
going to be borderline terrified to do
but there's a part of me that can't wait
for that and I was never an adrenaline
junkie I'm not a riding motorbikes and
jumping off cliffs and stuff like that
I'm not not one of those people but
one of my friends Bridget fetus is she's
a female comedian and she has a little
Mantra that she gives herself before she
goes on stage and she says I'm not
nervous I'm excited I'm not nervous I'm
excited and that reframe for me as well
is look I'm not stressed I'm excited I'm
not anxious this means something to me
and all of those opportunities you know
it doesn't matter how many cups of
coffee or nootropics or special
combinations of vitamins I take I can't
replicate the amount of focus and
attention that my body's going to give
me by it dumping tons and tons and tons
of neurotransmitters and hormones into
my body so I should be thanking it I
should be going look yeah it's narrowing
my focus but it's narrowing my focus
because this is the thing that I'm
focused on yeah yeah absolutely and it's
it's such a great example I mean that's
an example of sort of reframing and and
again when we're talking about
um you know can we change the mind with
the mind and stuff like that and I think
that's an example of when you can but um
you know you could do all of these sort
of you know breathing exercises but if
your main aim is to just get rid of that
uncomfortable feeling then you're going
to lose you know you can you can bring
down the intensity of it but if you're I
don't know about to go on live TV you're
going to feel anxious it's all brand new
to you and it's an intimidating
situation and there is genuine threat
that if you don't stay alert and do the
job you need to do you could be
humiliated or you could be upset about
it so you need that stress and I think
that's where when we change our
relationship with uncomfortable feelings
whether that's stress anxiety sadness
whatever those sort of uncutful feelings
are if we're willing to have them and
use them to our advantage and take them
with us
um then they don't hold us back you know
and when I talk about the sort of TV
example when I I did that recently
um I I felt that stress and I
acknowledged that was going to help me
do a good job so I took it with me I
didn't I didn't try to get rid of it I
used the sort of breathing techniques to
keep it at a level where I could focus I
noticed a catastrophizing thought so
this could go really wrong
yeah this is going to go terribly wrong
and then you you know you notice it and
then that enables you to let it go and
refocus on the thing at hand so you know
if you're willing to have that feeling
it will take its natural course which is
to rise and then fall again
do you suffer or have you suffered more
with any self-doubt or with dealing with
criticism now that you've had all of
these extra eyes on you obviously going
on TV and talking and then I mean Tick
Tock I wouldn't like to guess how many
millions of people you're reaching every
month on there is that something that's
Arisen for you or have you been able to
cope with that yeah I mean it's it's a
human thing isn't it and I think that's
what I say about a lot of these tools is
um they don't make you invincible they
don't ensure that you're going to have a
problem-free life and you're never going
to be touched by by doubt or grief or
stress ever again they are tools to
apply to those situations that you will
inevitably faced because they are part
of life and so
um yeah I mean throughout this whole
I've never had any
Ambitions to be a public person I I just
started sharing the educational aspect
of therapy because I thought actually
everyone's finding this really helpful
let's make it available why should
people have to pay to come and see
people like me to find out basic stuff
about how their brain works and so
I wanted to sort of make it available
but yeah I mean then you know quite a
little introvert who's used to working
in a room with one person at a time that
was pretty kind of exposing and and you
know you sort of uh you then are forced
to use the tools and practice what you
preach because you know putting yourself
I mean you probably understand as much
as as I do you know putting yourself out
there will kind of expose any sort of
insecurities or it will it will sort of
invite that voice of cell that
self-doubt to creep in
um so yeah I've had to you know use the
tools as much as the next person you are
spending at least a portion of your time
on Tick Tock making sure that the videos
look right that they've gone up
correctly probably checking comments to
see what do people think what are the
issues that they're coming up against
ideas from the new videos and such forth
how are you mediating your relationship
with technology with social media with
the super normal stimulus mechanisms
that it's giving us to ensure that it
doesn't impact your mental health too
much
um I've had I think something that's
hugely helped me is
that I had this clear reason for
starting that was just to be helpful and
to make some of this really incredible
information that's available in therapy
available to people who might not have
access to therapy
so that they could enhance their own
mental health and I it's been my mission
all the way along to stay close to that
so you know each video had to have some
thread of value in that front so whether
it was very entertaining and engaging or
not
um it had to have some level of message
there that could be helpful to people
and so a seed so
um that's helped a lot because it
enabled me to
um
not worry too much about how I looked or
whether you know sounded right or you
know those kind of things that
um especially as as a female online
there's a huge pressures to
um you know look certain ways and to
sound certain ways and and all of those
sorts of things so it always enabled me
to sort of come back to that whenever
those sort of pressures creeped in I was
able to come back to this is the reason
I'm here is to be helpful
um that kind of thing so I think that
always helps me
um I think also that I started this a
little bit later in life as well so that
I I already had a firm sense of who I
was or who I am and
um my values in life so always coming
back to what matters most to me I'm a
parent so having you know children and
understanding I think I always try to
shift to
uh when I'm in a difficult scenario what
would I want my children to have the
strength to do or believe about
themselves in this situation and because
I know that they won't do what I say
they'll do what I do so I have to live
that if I want them to you know be
confident and to face uncertainty or
face criticism with with self-belief
then I have to sort of live that out for
myself as well one of the things that
I've reframed recently around smartphone
use was
from it being an addiction to it being a
compulsion
and I think if I actually look at the
behavior for most people including
myself
over using your smartphone is a lot less
like an addiction and a lot more like
compulsive Behavior you pull your phone
out of your pocket without thinking
about it you're already moving your
fingers around the screen without even
thinking to the place where you know the
thing that you want that you need to get
now yeah sure perhaps the reward
mechanism that's pulling that through is
dopamine uh and but it does feel a lot
more like a compulsion and I think that
even though this is again arbitrary like
we said earlier on reframing the
terminology that you use from addiction
to compulsion has really changed that
this only happened over the last couple
of months perhaps which really changed
the way that I see my my smartphone use
I think look it's just compulsive you
know it's the same way as if because I
spent so long I did five years at Uni
and whatever 11 years in full-time
education before that if I put a pen in
my hand it starts spinning through my
fingers I don't think about it and I I
unless I think about stopping it I can't
stop it yeah
it's just a compulsion yeah yeah I mean
because I I guess
because of my clinical work I would I
sort of have a slightly different
conceptualization of of compulsion in
the sense that so within OCD for example
that compulsion is the thing that you
feel you have to do
because if not then something bad is
going to happen so it's often based on a
kind of threat response but you know I
would certainly definitely see that that
sort of
um it could even be the case actually
with with a with a phone that if I don't
take my phone with me I mean I have that
if I even if I go for a run
if I don't take my phone with me what if
what if something happens at home and
and my husband and the kids need me and
you know it could be 20 minutes before I
get back can you kind of and and but you
know it wasn't that long ago that that
was just something you did you know
people could live without you for half
an hour and and get through it but there
is that fear of if I haven't got
ultimate connection to everybody I know
something could happen and I won't know
about it there was something
about that and then then there's a sense
of Freedom you know if you go somewhere
and you lose all signal and your phone's
just you know obsolete then there's a
sense of sort of relief and freedom from
that isn't there that there is this sort
of fear of if I miss something if I miss
an email that's really important what's
going to happen and if I you know
um so maybe there is an element of that
um but also there is that habitual thing
of
um you just pull it out your back pocket
50 times a day and glance at it because
you have been doing that for five years
or whatever that's why I don't
understand people that go on planes and
then connect to the Wi-Fi
you have the opportunity now of being
completely liberated from access to the
outside world for yeah three to ten
hours or something that's for me is
bliss you load up a bunch of stuff onto
Kindle read through some things listen
to a podcast make some notes about stuff
that that's my favorite time but yeah I
think uh
it's very strange the fact that we feel
we feel like
the world is so interconnected and even
safer now than it was 20 years ago and
yet we there's this ambient level of
anxiety that we need to constantly be
contactable and available
um there's another concept that I
learned actually by a guy called
Benjamin Hardy and it's called The Gap
in the game and I've been thinking about
this a lot as I was going through your
book
so he talks about the gain being you
comparing the place that you're at now
to the place that you were at previously
and the Gap being you comparing where
you are now to the person that you want
to be and he writes about most people
live in the Gap rather than the gain and
he says it's like running toward the
Horizon that every time that you take a
step toward it the Horizon moves one
step further away and it just made me
think that I think a lot of the a lot of
the messages that we get about
self-worth and what success looks like
especially from social media is
inevitably comparing living in the Gap
it's living in that difference between
where somebody else is and this was
really highlighted when I did my first
Thanksgiving here in America uh in
November and it's an entire day that's
built around gratitude and you go around
the table individually and you sit there
and you say so what are the things that
you're most grateful for what were your
hugest wins this year why are you so
happy about things at the moment and um
all of that together just it really
resonated with me I think that that's
something that a lot more people should
try and bring into their life that model
yeah and I think it's a lot of what
happens in therapy actually is
um is getting a balance of those things
so sometimes someone will have
um just a natural sort of habit of doing
one or the other and and what we do is
we often
notice it so we'll we'll look at a
pattern look you know you keep going
there
what's the impact of that we'll step
back from it observe it and then try the
opposite and see what the impact of that
is and so we're never trying to
completely not do something or only do
the other thing actually there's Merit
in doing all of those at different times
with a certain
um if they're constructive you know if
if there's a certain goal in mind so it
is helpful to look back and say look how
far I've come but it's also helpful to
look forward and say okay where next and
it's often
with what sort of flavor are you doing
that you know are you are you constantly
saying I'm not I'm not there yet and I'm
not there yet and then therefore you're
sacrificing how you feel today and and
being present and potentially being
happy in the moment
um or are you are you saying uh you know
that's where I'm aiming for
and here's where I've been yes I'm on
the right path this is what's next you
know without that without
um filling it with kind of self-loathing
or self-criticism that then holds you
back it's always looking I mean I love
looking at all of sort of the
psychological work with sort of sports
psychology in mind and professional
athletes you know and if you think about
I don't know we've just had Wimbledon
here in in London and if you think about
a professional tennis player they will
do exactly that with a coach they will
they will look at how far they've come
and they will look specifically at what
has helped them to come that fast so far
and what they need to hold on to and
then they'll look at where they want to
go next what the hurdles are and how to
break those down and what strengths are
going to help them to get there and so
it's always just balancing those but I
think the key to having that balance is
being aware of what you're doing in the
first place it's all about awareness
it's noticing so rather than being stuck
in your head it's sort of watching what
happens in your head saying oh wow look
when I'm constantly thinking about
that past event then I'm held back or
when I'm constantly moving the goal post
for my future I'm actually I'm not
living in the present and I'm really
unhappy or you know it's only by by
getting that bird's eye view of
everything including what's happening in
our own heads that we can kind of see
our way out talking about things from
the past that keep coming up how can
people not be too defined by previous
mistakes
I think
you know when it comes to the Mind sort
of going back and that tendency to
ruminate you know rumination is one of
the a big sort of maintaining factors
for depression and and
um you know it will sort of predict
relapse and those sorts of things if you
have that tendency to go to the Past
something you regret specifically or or
you know a painful experience and then
just turn it over and over again and so
that kind of ruminating that happens
um
I think again there is that element of
awareness so being able to notice when
you're doing that so that you can choose
whether to keep engaging in it or
whether to step back and do something
different and you know sometimes people
will will employ a really kind of simple
tool where once they've noticed that
they're doing that thing
they literally kind of say stop and they
they you know put the hand up and they
say it out loud and then they activate
and they do something different they
move on and they focus on something in
the present so that might be you know it
could be any activity that sort of
grounds them in the here and now
um or movement and exercise is great for
that that shifts you into your body as
opposed to your mind and those kind of
things so um but yeah I mean rumination
is a about sort of past events is a
really big predictor of you know sort of
relapse for depression so it's really
important to to tackle that given the
choice between getting a night's sleep
or going to the gym in terms of
resetting my mood I would choose going
to the gym I think that I have more
bleed from night to morning than I do
from pre to post workout in terms of the
way that I am and yeah I think that it's
not for everybody but if far more people
than would realize it but if you go and
play a game of
tennis badly or something even with just
a friend that try and focus as you're
trying to hit the ball desperately
across the court the fact that you've
got something in your hand it's tactile
the smells The Sounds you're moving your
sweat like just that I think is such a
big element of it and that's what I
appreciated about huberman's work that
yeah maybe maybe I think that you're
probably right on balance that there are
elements especially if you look at CBT
and how effective that can be for people
like that is about reframing I'm not I'm
not doing a CBT with my hands
um but that the definitely getting into
the body is something that's interesting
another interesting thing that I liked
that you did was you talked about
turning bad days into good days and this
was something that I was doing when I
had low mood throughout my 20s that one
of the the wins that I would put down in
my journal was that I had a good bad day
uh and it was so funny to see that pop
up in your book as well
yeah I mean I there's a whole sort of
you know section there on
you know shifting from those bad days
often there's that misconception that if
you're working on something that every
day should be a little bit better than
the last and and often there's a classic
sort of example or something that will
happen in therapy someone will start
making progress quite quickly and
they'll see a bit of change just from
the fact that they they're coming to
appointments and they're talking openly
and and it feels safe and those kind of
things and then you know things will
happen because life happens right and
and you have a bad day or a bad week
and then they feel low and and you tell
yourself when you're in that place
um that where I started I'm I'm back at
square one I've got to start all over
again and
and half of the sort of lesson that you
learn is you're not back where you
started you can't undo the progress that
you've made so far part of that journey
of of being well is having bad days and
then bringing yourself back to Baseline
and back up and and so you know it's not
that you work on something and then
every day is just neutral and fine it's
that that you learn these skills to be
able to sort of haul yourself back up
when you've had a tough day because you
know the things that work and you know
the things that will keep you stuck
um so it's all about sort of
having that awareness of yourself and
what works for you so that you can
respond to those bad days rather than
never having them what about mood
pitfalls that people should look out for
um I think yes movement is a is a huge
one and and actually it in the you know
when I've worked with people who have a
severe depression
um often in in sort of acute hospitals
and things
um a One hospital I worked at we had the
the benefit of having a lovely garden
and in appointments for people I would
would start by walking around the garden
with them as we talked because simply
getting your body moving starts to shift
things and it starts to you know it
doesn't take all your problems away
it doesn't change your your situation
your circumstances but it starts to
shift your biology and can bring someone
to a level where they're more able then
to engage in the more complex
psychological stuff that's going to help
them longer term so you get this
incredible shift from from any form of
exercise and I think it's such a shame
that exercise has been sort of over the
years made to seem like it's supposed to
be
this ultimate graft where you put
yourself through grueling pain in order
to look different and be more you know
aesthetically pleasing to other people
because it creates this sort of
impression that exercise has to be that
way exercise can be
putting on music and dancing around your
kitchen with your family you know you
can be moving your body in any sort of
way and that's going to help it's going
to to make your
it's going to shift your biology it's
going to shift your how you feel
um all of those sorts of things so you I
think part of the work that we do is
helping people to increase their level
of movement
um without it feeling like a chore or
something that you've got to endure
because when you're already enduring
depression that's that's enough already
I suppose as well there's this brutal
feedback loop when it comes to mood that
La mood causes people to move less to do
less to not eat to not contact other
people which then creates a cycle of
worse mood which is that sort of ever
increasing spiral
yeah absolutely you get stuck in that
cycle of you know low mood gives you the
urge to do the things that keep you
stuck so it will you know you'll wake up
for whatever reason it could be it could
be anything that's induced that low mood
it could be could be something huge like
grief or it could be something like
um you know you're dehydrated or your
child was up a couple of times in the
night and so you haven't really had
enough sleep and so you wake up feeling
groggy and low and then you have the
urge to call in sick or
um you know not meet your friend later
on or skip the gym or do all of those
things and you say you have the urge to
kind of close everything down and avoid
doing the things that actually in the
long time are going to help you
um just being aware of that again just
knowing that increases the chances that
in that moment where you get to choose
you could choose the right thing
it's going to help you in the long term
you won't always right sometimes you'll
still go around that cycle and you'll
kind of you know suffer the consequences
of that mood wise but sometimes you'll
you'll acknowledge yes I know that I
have the urge to not answer my phone to
my friends and family when I'm low but I
know where that leads so today I'm going
to force myself to do it and then you
get the benefits of it what have you
come to believe about what a meaningful
life consists of
so uh that's a sort of a fairly big
section of the book and and it's
something that's often looked at in
acceptance and commitment therapy
um I find that a lot of people
who come to therapy with a limited idea
of what's really going on they'll say
you know I'm okay but everything just
feels a bit empty I feel a bit lost I'm
just not really sure where I'm going
there's just no meaning in anything
so many times that has happened where
life has pulled someone away from what's
meaningful to them and what matters most
to them because that's what happens
right you know and and so in therapies
like ACT therapy except as a commitment
therapy
you just help someone to get clarity on
what matters to them and what what their
values are and that can be quite sort of
crudely done you know you can write
things down on a piece of paper split
your life into the different areas you
know maybe Intimate Relationships family
relationships parenting career learning
creativity Faith all of those different
things that fill people's lives
and you just write down
words bullet points ideas not what you
want to happen to you but the kind of
person you want to be in that area of
your life through good times or bad how
do you want to show up
how do you want to show up as a parent a
colleague a partner all of those kind of
things so it's not a goal that you
achieve and then it's done it's a path
that doesn't really end but you always
try to steer close to it
um and
when you do when you do this kind of
exercise and these kind of values
check-ins I put in the book you
you okay you acknowledge these are the
things that are important to me in this
area of my life
and how how closely am I living in line
with those at the moment and if if the
answer is not very much so if you rate
it as really high in terms of how
important it is to you but in terms of
living in line with it is pretty low and
there's that Gap it just gives you that
indication that you can shift Direction
and it might be some small decisions
that you make about your day-to-day life
that shift that direction so that you
feel you're living more in line with the
person you want to be and the life that
you want to live and the contribution
that you want to make a lot of people I
think feel like they have control over
the the surface level stuff that they do
so they're maybe habits and the way that
they show up on a daily basis but not
the larger direction that their life is
is moving in what about making large
meaningful changes in life is that
simply a case of day by day steps or is
there is there something else missing
from that
um well I guess you know you can make
huge big life-changing decisions
um but often
often they're broken down into those
smaller steps aren't they and and
actually when you're looking at
um life decisions in terms of your
mental health
we we always ask why that's why people
get so frustrated with therapy that it
takes a long time right because that's
how we work we don't we don't often
sustain big Grand changes and gestures
that that are live transforming
overnight we the the changes we can
sustain are those smaller ones that that
enable us to
um
make a make a shift that we can sustain
every day and then once that becomes
habitual then we can keep that going and
without too much effort and then we can
shift on to the next change so we create
big change most effectively and
sustainably with lots of small changes
that add up I certainly see that in
myself the person I am now versus the
person that I was 10 years ago five
years ago even three years ago it's very
very different and that it it's so
strange how change works that it does
creep up on you I actually don't realize
that it's happened until you one day
some something causes you to reminisce
about the way that you would have dealt
with something previously or about a
memory of a situation that you managed
to get yourself into and the way that
you responded to it you go I I it's
really kind of hard for me to recognize
that person and that mental state I
always thought it would be cool if you
could take snapshots of the Mind in the
same way that you can take a photograph
and then you could go back and visit the
old texture of your mind from five years
ago or ten years ago because it would be
so Stark the difference the things that
would have captured your attention the
thoughts and the concerns that you would
have had about yourself or the world or
whatever and now you're a million miles
away from that but it's hard to go back
and remember that because you're not
that anymore and there isn't that
photograph for you to go back and view
yeah and it's it's like a sort of
finding some old Journal isn't it and
then reading about the things that you
were worried about you know 10 years ago
or when you were a kid and you think oh
you know it seems like such a a huge
period of time between then and now and
actually you know it's a really useful
skill to be able to
create future self memories so where you
imagine yourself in the future uh in
detail and you look back at the choices
that you're making now or are about to
make and you consider how you would feel
about that you know what what choices if
you if you're putting yourself into
itself five years from now what choices
would you be most proud of and how would
you feel about that and what would be
the focus of your attention the main
focus of your attention
in the future self and and what you know
what would you be like and why and
what choices would have held you back
and what things would have propelled you
forward and and those sorts of things
and so that can be really helpful again
in focusing on the choices you're making
today and making sure that they are
benefiting you in the long term as
opposed to
um responding to how I want to feel
today the best uh thought experiment
that I think in terms of working out
what would be a good way to spend your
time or the things that you should focus
on is to think okay at the end of this
year what would have had to have
happened for me to look back on this
year and consider it a success and that
little bit of distancing a little bit of
future planning a little bit of sort of
reflecting I I did that with covid um
during the lockdown okay what would have
had to have happened by the end of
lockdown for me to look back and
consider it a success and it was so good
it was the by far all of the planning
all of the journaling all of that stuff
was good for the daily practice but in
terms of big picture stuff I just
thought well okay what what would I have
wanted me to do and it's you it's you
you know you know you pretty well you
know what you would have wanted you to
do but it's just that little bit
distance it's a little bit of future
planning
yeah and it's so useful to be able to
ask yourself in any difficult moment
um what response will I be most proud of
in this situation how can you know and
and it sometimes just gives us that
guide post to to shift our Direction and
and behave and turn up in the way that
we want to
um as opposed to sort of reacting and
feeling out of control
Dr Julie Smith ladies and gentlemen if
people want to follow you online and
check out the stuff that you do where
should they go uh either Instagram
YouTube
um Dr Julie and uh yeah sharing lots of
sort of insights from therapy
um that people can use in everyday life
Julie I appreciate you thank you and you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace